bienvenue chez la compagnie de contraire
maintenant je vais vous présenter notre
chapiteau le repaire de contraire donné
le 2 novembre 2019 le château de la
compagnie des contraire été victime d'un
incendie avec le soutien de la région
ile de france
elle a pu racheter et mettre en place un
nouveau chapiteau dans la période de
transition qui a eu les ateliers de
cirque on continue et on a eu un
partenariat avec le collège major langue
qui nous accepter et l'économie le
visage et on n'a pas du tout arrêter le
travail jusqu'à l'implantation du
chapiteau le repère des contraires
prépare à toutes les disciplines du
cirque et permet l'expression artistique
objectif rendre la culture accessible à
tous un travail d'insertion sociale
toujours la campagne était en cirque
social et nous sommes une équipe
d'artistes engagés vraiment pour le
développement de l'éducation populaire
surtout dans les quartiers sensibles
autre projet de la compagnie le cabanon
une galerie à ciel ouvert implanté en
2008 il a marqué le début du repaire des
contraires depuis une dizaine d'artistes
à travailler dessus ça c'est devenu
voilà notre galerie
si vous pouvez voir le travail de
sandrine avant guerre qui sait une
mosaïste ça c'était un travail
d'insertion qui a commencé en 2017
la compagnie des contraires fêtera ses
30 ans le 11 juillet prochain
part à des manifestations seront
organisées à cette occasion
[Musique]